your doctor may perform a bra
Casca be to look for and diagnose
problems inside your lungs your nose and
mouth our points of entry for air to
move in and out of your lungs through
your trachea or windpipe and bronchial
tubes with each breath your lungs inhale
oxygen and exhale carbon dioxide this
exchange of gases is the way your body
gets oxygen into your blood
a bronchoscopy may be done to look for
and possibly retrieve a foreign object
that may have been inhaled instead of
swallowed investigate a persistent cough
or a cough producing blood obtain a
mucous tissue or liquid sample from
inside your lungs or evaluate an
abnormal chest x-ray or CT scan before
your procedure you will receive
medication to help you relax and
minimize coughing an intravenous line
will be inserted for additional
medications your heart and blood
pressure will be monitored and you will
be given extra oxygen during the
procedure you will be given either a
local anesthetic to numb your throat or
general anesthesia
during the procedure your doctor will
slowly thread a bronchoscope through
your nose or mouth down your throat past
your vocal cords through your trachea
and into your bronchial tubes he or she
will carefully examine the lining of
your Airways and may take samples for
laboratory examination or remove a
foreign object after the procedure you
will be taken to a recovery area if a
biopsy has been taken you will likely
have a chest x-ray before you leave the
hospital your doctor will send any mucus
liquid or biopsy samples removed from
your lungs to a laboratory for
examination the results of which should
be available within a week